Chris waters here with a gamespot news
update gamespot editors have already
chosen our official winners of e3 my
personal favorite was evolved but we
also gave you the viewers a chance to
vote on your favorites and the results
are in to be eligible for voting the
games had to be playable at e3 so games
with sweet trailers like The Legend of
Zelda on the Wii U and the division work
included the first place winner of the
game spot People's Choice Award for 2014
is the witcher 3 wild hunt which secured
twenty-three percent of the votes we got
our first glimpse of gameplay at e3 and
it looks truly amazing dragon age
inquisition came in second place with
twelve percent of the vote and super
smash brothers for Wii U got third
overall with nine percent there were
also individual console categories and
interestingly enough both Sony and
Microsoft consoles ended up with the
same winner ps4 Xbox one and PC gamers
all voted for The Witcher 3 while ps3
and xbox 360 players both chose dragon
age inquisition Wii U and 3ds owners
chose their respective versions of super
smash brothers while Vita players chose
freedom wars so what do you think were
you on Team Daryl cheering your victory
or were you on team Kraken with me and a
little disappointed that evolve didn't
make it up there but wait it's not
really any disappointment involved here
because these are all awesome games that
were just all getting excited about for
more on these awesome games stay tuned
to gamespot
you